[Musica]
è stato a marzo del 2019 che sono potuta
salire su questo ponte che avevo
percorso tante volte con la macchina e
il ponte non c'era più cioè c'era ma era
incompleto ne mancava un pezzo mi sono
portato sul ciglio e ho guardato
dall'orlo il percorso che mancava cioè
quella famosa campata numero 9 che era
crollata con le appendici e quindi
questo che si vede è proprio un vuoto
che rappresentava proprio il dramma che
era avvenuto da questo momento il mio
incarico era di eliminare insieme a un
raggruppamento di imprese molto efficaci
di eliminare questa questo punto di
riferimento per i genovesi tanto che
anche nelle cartoline appariva il ponte
morandi come se fosse un luogo
assolutamente di riferimento per genova
e a questo punto a a me esplosivista
toccavano 10 rogne la prima rogna erano
le dimensioni quando hanno costruito il
ponte c'erano già dei condomini di otto
nove piani e avevano smussato persino i
cornicioni per far passare i pilastri
che servivano per sostenere gli
impalcati su cui le macchine sarebbero
poi passate quindi la prima ragnar alle
dimensioni perché non è che uno dice beh
tanto tanto grande e l'edificio tanto
esplosivo metti problema è che con tanto
esplosivo e anche degli effetti
collaterali che vorresti eliminare
la seconda rogna qualcuno dice forse
dentro il ponte cioè dell'amianto che
viene da un minerale che si chiama
ofiolite una roccia che si chiama
ofiolite e che è presente per sé un
terzo di tutto l'appennino tosco ligure
emiliano questa ofiolite può contenere
tracce di amianto e quindi l'ordine
assoluto era mitigare le polveri ci sono
dei metodi tradizionali
non bastavano ci volevano metodi
straordinari e quindi abbiamo cominciato
a mettere delle sacche di acqua tutto
intorno alle zone di pilastro in cui
mettevamo la
le cariche esplosive ma ancora non
bastava quindi abbiamo sperimentato in
una cava delle trincee piene d'acqua e
le abbiamo fatte saltare per vedere fino
a che altezza riuscivamo a far arrivare
quest'acqua con l'esplosivo e quanto
tempo ci metteva a ricadere quest'acqua
è come si nebulizza va visto il
risultato ottimale sfruttando i new
jersey del ponte
abbiamo costruito queste piscine
oblunghe un chilometro e mezzo di
piscine alcune sopra a gli impalcati e
due file ai piedi del ponte in modo da
poter avere la massima copertura d'acqua
intorno a quello che doveva collassare
la terza rogna erano gli stralli nuovi
cioè quelli che erano stati rifatti
sulla campata 11 che andavano ad
ancorarsi purtroppo proprio sotto il
viadotto della 7 e in questa slide si
intravede in basso a sinistra
gli strali che arrivano e vanno a finire
esattamente sotto questo viadotto non
tagliarli prima dell'abbattimento del
ponte poteva significare trascinarsi
dietro tutto il tutto il viadotto della
7 quindi chiudendo anche un'altra strada
per tagliare questi strali abbiamo
chiesto aiuto ai militari che ci
fornissero più velocemente di quanto
avrei potuto fare io delle cariche
speciali e le abbiamo sperimentate e
funzionavano però ce ne voleva tanto di
questo celtics e quindi con tutto questo
sempre che serviva abbiamo dovuto fare
una triangolazione fra corpi speciali
italiani per far arrivare l'occorrente
di questo di questo razor 40 questo
esplosivo a base di sente spesso serviva
per tagliare l'acciaio avevamo 32 di
questi tre folli d'acciaio da tagliare
una quinta rogna era la l'elicoidale e
che praticamente era una struttura
circolare che si andava ad abbracciare
riagganciare
all al viadotto sparito e questa era una
struttura molto esile aveva dei pilastri
molto sottili quindi dovevamo preservare
assolutamente quella la sesta rogna era
gestire le esigenze di tutti il sindaco
bucci in questa immagine simpaticamente
mostra la pressione anche alla fine del
lavoro per rispettare i tempi perché
ogni giorno di ponte su voleva dire
rallentare anche la ricostruzione quindi
dare un disagio a tutti i genovesi che
dovevano fare
grandissimo giro ogni volta per
bypassare il ponte che non c'era più
e poi c'erano i famigerati detonatori
legati a questa esigenza di fare in
fretta io ho voluto fortemente dei
detonatori speciali elettronici perché
sapendo di dover temporizzare un mare di
cose
volevo questi detonatori erano la
ferrari day dei detonatori e quindi non
voleva utilizzare una seicento che erano
magari alcune delle tipologie che potevo
utilizzare con più facilità
però questi detonatori sono arrivati in
ritardo perché dovevano partire dalla
spagna e in francia sono stati
trattenuti non si sa perché per qualche
giorno quindi alla fine abbiamo dovuto
mandare la polizia alla frontiera di
ventimiglia per guadagnare tempo perché
comunque il tempo era fondamentale la
settima rogna e che la settimana di
giugno del 2019 è stata una delle più
calde del secolo e la dinamite al brutto
vizio di tra sudare cioè di espellere
quello che il suo principio attivo cioè
la nitroglicerina
quindi il pensiero numero uno era di ebe
visto che la devi mettere nell'acqua per
sollevare l'acqua appunto per mitigare
le polveri in acqua sta stahl al fresco
no perché l'acqua comunque lentamente
scioglie i principi attivi
dell'esplosivo facendogli perdere di
potenza quindi alla fine ho dovuto
scegliere emettere l'esplosione l'acqua
ma incrementandolo considerando la
perdita di potenza che ci sarebbe stata
tenendo l'esplosivo in acqua l'ottava
rogna era interferenza con le altre
maestranze non potevamo lavorare
senza i gruisti o senza quelli che
tiravano i tubi con cui avremmo irrigato
la parte sottostante il ponte e quindi
avevamo dei fili molto delicati che
passavano in tutto il cantiere e ogni
volta che qualcuno pestava questo filo
la centralina elettronica ci segnalava
l'anomalia e dovevamo andare a
sostituire un pezzo e questo erano ha
paura che abbiamo avuto fino all'ultimo
momento perché è ovviamente la gente è
andata è venuta fino proprio all'ultimo
momento la nona rogna è stata la
pressione mediatica un certo punto il
giorno prima dell'esplosione
qualche giornalista ha messo la mia foto
in prima pagina con una uscita anche un
po così da presuntuoso non faccia
saltare il ponte non erano parole mie
non era mia volontà essere come dire
così tracotante nel prepararmi a questa
operazione
e questo comunque è servito a trovare il
futuro eventuale capo capro espiatorio
qualora qualcosa fosse andato storto
la decima rogna era stato il fattore
tempo dovevamo bagnare sotto il ponte in
modo che quando cascavano le campate non
sollevassero ulteriore polvere per cui
dovevamo creare un mezzo acquitrino per
questo abbiamo posizionato 12 lance da
irrigazione che però avevano 20 minuti
di autonomia dentro questi venti minuti
io avevo undici minuti per far caricare
i condensatori che servono ad attivare i
detonatori
il problema è che se non usi poi entro
il dodicesimo minuto questa corrente il
sistema si scarica e quindi hai bisogno
di altri undici minuti e quindi
bisognava far collimare i venti minuti
di irrigazione con gli undici minuti di
caricamento dei condensatori dentro gli
undici minuti dovevo far stare cinque
minuti con i quali le persone che
avevano acceso le pompe degli idranti e
le centraline per il rilevamento delle
polveri si riportassero a in zona di
sicurezza dentro i cinque minuti dovevo
suonare la sirena e portarmi io stesso
in zona protetta
quindi tre minuti dei cinque negli
undici nei 20 tutto va bene se hai un
orario
milito che erano le 9 purtroppo pochi
pochi minuti dopo le 8 viene segnalata
una persona all'interno di uno dei
palazzi che stavano sotto al al ponte e
che quindi dovevano essere sgomberati
questo mi fece portare per 15 minuti più
avanti il tempo di demolizione quindi 9
un quarto però poi l'inquilino che
doveva essere sgomberato e non dava
segno di voler aprire e quindi hanno
deciso di segare la porta blindata il
muro della porta blindata io ricevevo
queste notizie dal funzionario della
questura che stava di fianco a me e
quindi ho spostato alle nove e mezza
vedendo che il lavoro perdurava alla
fine ho detto ok quando la persona sarà
fuori faremo partire gli idranti faremo
partire tutto e quindi ho dovuto
spostare questa piramide due o tre volte
nel tempo
alla fine quando è arrivato l'input che
le persone erano state evacuate che la
strada era chiusa che si poteva sparare
mancava il feedback di uno delle dodici
persone che aveva acceso le centraline
non arrivava a questo feedback
semplicemente perché aveva le pile
scariche della radio
quindi a un certo punto c'è stato
bisogno che uno della squadra andasse a
vedere come mai questa dodicesima
persona non rispondeva anche quando ho
avuto questo feedback
a questo punto ho fatto partire tutti i
conteggi e in un orecchio avevo
l'addetto al caricamento dei
condensatori che mi diceva in quanto
tempo avrei perso poi il turno del
dell'accensione c'è stato un problema
alla fine abbiamo potuto
operare nei tempi previsti a caso cioè
le 9 37 però con rispettando la
tempistica che ci eravamo prefissati e e
alla fine il lavoro è stato eseguito con
il conto alla rovescia e tutto è andato
poi secondo quello che è stato visto da
tutte le persone e come vedremo nel
filmato che andremo a vedere fra poco il
famoso dito sul pulsante era in realtà
una console ed ecco il famoso della
famosa console con scritto fire era il
tasto che è stato premuto e questo è il
risultato che ci eravamo prefissati
quindi il muro d'acqua che stava sopra
al ponte si è sollevato mentre
cominciava a scendere il muro d'acqua
abbiamo cominciato a far scendere con le
temporizzazioni dei detonatori anche le
cariche che toglievano gli appoggi
quindi cominciava a scendere insieme il
ponte e mentre il ponte scendeva
cominciavano a salire i muri d'acqua che
avevamo messo al piede e quindi grazie a
questo sistema si è creato una sorta di
tunnel d'acqua che ha imbrigliato tutto
il polverone che si sarebbe generato con
un'operazione del genere
alla fine sono stati 500 i chili di
dinamite che abbiamo usato per
frantumare il cemento armato e 180 chili
di dinamite per sollevare l'acqua 30 kg
è stato il semtex necessario a tagliare
gli stralli abbiamo messo 5000 metri di
una miccia detonante una corda una corda
detonante sole per sollevare 3 milioni
di litri d'acqua con un chilometro e
mezzo di vasche 30 mila litri d'acqua
sono stati sparati sotto il ponte prima
che questa operazione iniziasse e il
tutto ha comportato l'evacuazione di
circa 3.000 persone
5 4 3 2 1 cuoco
le immagini parlano più di tante parole
e quindi sono lieto di questa
spettacolarizzazione anche di un evento
che comunque era l'appendice di un
episodio drammatico della nostra storia
per parecchie ore dopo l'abbattimento o
non ho realizzato quello che era stato
fatto perché dovevo esplorare le macerie
alla ricerca di eventuali cariche
inesplose cosa che sapevo benissimo non
essersi perché con questo sistema di
collegamento che avevo predisposto o
partiva tutto o non partiva niente però
era una delle prescrizioni a cui ero
obbligato e dopo sono stato come dire
coinvolto dalla folla che era nel
quartiere e che voleva fare i self i ma
ancora non avevo realizzato bene tutta
l'operazione finché uno dei 500 sms che
ho ricevuto
nei minuti dopo l'abbattimento che ho
guardato mentre tornavo a casa a parma
in macchina mi ha fatto rendere conto
perché un alto funzionario del ministero
mi ha scritto così
e lì ho capito che abbiamo rischiato di
fare una figuraccia in mondovisione e
sono molto lieto invece di essere stato
l'artefice oltre che l'artificiere di un
abbattimento ben riuscito quindi ha
portato ha tenuto alto l'onore
dell'italia grazie